the spirit of solidarity that we have
seen today is what we need not just to
prevent and mitigate the impact of
future pandemics
but
to end this one
the emergence of the omicron variant has
understandably captured global attention
at least 23 countries from five of six
wha regions have now reported
cases of omicron and we expect that
number to grow
who takes this development extremely
seriously
and so should every country
but it should not surprise us
this is
what viruses do
and it's what this virus will continue
to do as long as we allow it to continue
spreading
we're learning more
all the time about omicron
but there is still more to learn about
its effect on transmission
severity of disease
and the effectiveness of tests
therapeutics and vaccines
several wh advisory groups have met over
the last couple of days to evaluate the
emerging evidence
and prioritize the studies needed to
answer these questions
i thank botswana in south africa for
detecting sequencing and reporting this
variant so rapidly
it's deeply concerning to me that those
countries are now being penalized by
others for doing the right thing
we call on all countries to take
rational
proportional risk reduction measures
in keeping with international health
regulations
this includes measures to delay or
reduce the spread of the new variant
such as screening of passengers prior to
traveling and or upon arrival
or the application of quarantine to
international travelers
blanket travel bans will not prevent the
international spread of omicron
and they place a heavy burden on lives
and livelihoods
who continues to call on all countries
to optimize public health and social
measures
and ensure that high-risk and vulnerable
individuals in all countries are fully
vaccinated immediately
at the same time
we must not forget that we are already
dealing with a highly transmissible
dangerous variant the delta variant
which currently accounts for almost all
cases globally
we need to use the tools we already have
to prevent transmission and save lives
from delta
and if we do that
we will also prevent transmission and
save lives from omicron
but if countries and individuals don't
do what they need to do to stop
transmission of delta
they wouldn't stop omicron either
globally
we have a toxic mix of low vaccine
coverage
and very low testing
a recipe for breeding and amplifying
variants
that's why we continue to urge countries
to fully fund the act accelerator
to ensure equitable access to vaccines
tests therapeutics
all over the world
as we mark world aids day
we're reminded that more than 40 years
into the global aids epidemic
we still have no vaccine
and no cure for this disease
two years into the kobit 19 pandemic
we have not one
but many vaccines
and many other effective tools
this virus has demonstrated that it will
not
simply disappear
how many more lives and livelihoods it
takes is up to us
ending the pandemic is not a matter of
chance
it is a matter of
choice